اخيرا ريال مدريد يعلن عن صفته المنتظره
[موسيقى]
برشلونه يعود لصفقات الاعاره
وزيدان يلمح لعودته الى التدريب
هذه الاخبار وغيرها نقدمها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
اعلن ريال مدريد اخيرا عن صفقته المنتظره
بعد تعقدها رسميا مع نجم خط الوسط
الانجليزي جود بعقد يمتد حتى عام 2009
وتشير التقارير الا ان سعر الصفقه بلغ 113
مليون يورو ليصبح بيلينغام بعد هذا
الانتقال اغلى لاعب انجليزي في التاريخ
كما يعد سابعه لاعب انجليزي يمثل ريال
مدريد والاول منذ رحيل الاسطوره
عام 2007
[موسيقى]
ومع وصول بيلينغام ووجود كما فينجا
والعديد من العناصر الشابه في ريال مدريد
قد يبدا الثنائي كروس ومدريج فعليا في
التفكير بمغادره الفريق خاصه وان النادي
لم يعلن رسميا تجديده عقدهما حتى الان
وتطالب جماهير الفريق الملكي في الموسم
الجديد في الاعتماد عن الجيل الشاب في خط
الوسط والهجوم مع عقد المزيد من الصفقات
لدعم خط الدفاع
[موسيقى]
وبعد الاعلان عن رحيلي جوردي البا عن نادي
برشلونه كشفت صحيفه سبورت الكتالونيا بان
البارصا يسعى لضم كانسيلو لاعب مانشستر
سيتي على سبيل الاعاره الا ان نادي
الانجليزيه يريد بيعه بشكل نهائي ويبدو ان
البرتغالي قد اصبح غير مرغوب به من طرف
البرجولا خاصه بعد الطريقه التي غادر بها
نحو بايرن ميونخ شهر يناير الماضي
يبدو ان النجم الفرنسي زين الدين زيدان قد
اشتاق للملاعب والتدريب بعد سنتين قضاهما
بعيدا عن الاضواء وكشف زيزو في مقابله مع
مجله جيكيو الفرنسيه ان رغبته بالعوده
للتدريب ويشعر بانه مفعم بالطاقه وكانت
عده عده تقارير انجليزيه وايطاليه قد ربطت
زيدان بتدريب فريقه مانشستر يونايتد
ويوفنتوس بعد ضياع فرصه قياده المنتخب
الفرنسي في الوقت الحالي
[موسيقى]